[Music]
like most other weddings in history all
British royal weddings begin with the
engagement but unlike regular weddings
these ones involve an elaborately
choreographed event that will be watched
by an audience of million of the first
decisions a couple makes is deciding
where to actually do the thing if
they're really into history in tradition
there's really only one choice from the
solemnity of the gabbie but not this
time
the big change is this wedding between
Prince Harry and Megan Markham you don't
have all the ambassadors from all the
different countries you don't have heads
of state coming to this wedding one
reason is because the chapel wins that
can only take 600 people and therefore
the city isn't space but it's also
clearly the desire of Prince Harry
informal wedding around two months
before the big day the Lord
Chamberlain's office sends out
individually handcrafted invitations
there's flowers and fittings and the
entirety of the city to prepare while
the bride and groom had to sleep in
different homes spectators who want a
decent view of the public processions
will be sleeping outside and just a few
hours later some traveled hundreds or
even thousands of miles the general rule
of royal weddings is the less important
you are the earlier you arrive and the
further back you sit if you're there
representing a charity if you're a
member of the Armed Forces or a
celebrity you're relegated to the nave
of the church which means you might not
even get to see the actual ceremony
close friends of the bride and groom and
other guests will head in at least an
hour and a half before most of the time
it is groom up at the front the royal
procession comes in order precedence
which means the more junior Royals come
first and last comes the queen and her
husband
as as they come and then the bride turns
up when the bride arrives the details of
the dress are finally revealed after
months of top secrecy I am beside myself
this is such a fashion moment with a
color and regardless of who the designer
is she'll be wearing white and will
carry a sprig of Myrtle in her bouquet
which symbolizes love and marriage both
of which are trends started by Queen
Victoria the bride CR is almost always
the Something Borrowed likely from one
of the family's collection of jewels
since 1923 the ring placed on the
bride's finger is always made from Welsh
gold Elizabeth and Diana's rings even
came from the same nugget the ceremony
is performed by the Archbishop of
Canterbury and only takes about an hour
towards the end the bridegroom and their
two witnesses go into a private room to
sign the register at that point the
wedding is sanctified in law as it was
sanctified by religious service
officially married the bride and groom
exit closely followed by the procession
of the Queen there's any heart that
hasn't been run over by her today it can
kindly surrender now there's a good
chance you'll hear pomp and circumstance
around this time although Americans
associate it with high school
graduations it was originally written
for the coronation of King Edward the
seventh the bride and groom will likely
make their way into the open 1902 State
Land out for the official carriage
procession around the city that's when
the crowds who have been waiting for
hours or possibly days will get their
first look at the royal couple this
usually concludes with the iconic
appearance on the buckingham palace
balcony on which Diana and Charles were
the first to kiss the kiss is a critical
moment in the entire royal wedding
ceremony you don't just throw it away in
the middle of church it has to be seen
live by hundreds of thousands of
people's and just in case anyone have
missed it Prince William suggests one
more piece
because Megan and Harry's wedding is 20
miles outside of London their first
public kiss as a married couple will
have to happen somewhere else
afterwards the wedding party takes
official photos and ceremony guests
gather for the wedding breakfast
complete with a traditional fruit cake
though in the past the bride and groom
would change clothes and depart their
honeymoon directly afterwards current
Royals have gone for a more modern
approach with a real party and they will
be the only ones celebrating is
generally seen as an excuse to have a
good time and somewhat buttoned up Brits
who don't really have a good time in
public that much let their hair down and
enjoy themselves in the middle of their
street at that point it's a pretty
normal wedding reception although normal
ones don't generally include rumoured
performances by Elton John and the Spice
Girls the row couple will head off for
the honeymoon which is almost certainly
within the British Commonwealth while
the rest of the country nurses a
hangover as they lead an exhilarated
exhausted London for them as for any
newlyweds The Adventure is just about to
begin
you